there's always a Wells he knows I'm
working with someone he doesn't know
with whom you're working yeah how can
you be sure because if he did your
father would be here right now in a
flash so I need to put his hand right
through my heart you're barred if my
father finds out you've been helping me
try to catch a cicada behind his back
hey Shh this can all be fixed I can fix
this
hey everybody it's Charlie this is gonna
be my flash season five episode 13 video
in an explainer for that mini arrow
crossover the reverse flash is gonna
make everything alright though no
worries it's totally not gonna go
sideways
there's a new round of the reverse flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite moment from the episode on the
video careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen it yet top 10 WTF and comic
book Easter eggs starting with number 10
reverse flash and Nora's brand new plan
so as you can see reverse flashes
totally behind Nora's plan to distract
Sherlock with the earth one version of
his ex-wife in the hopes that he'll be
so obsessed with her that he won't think
about what Nora's doing long enough for
her in reverse flash to enact their plan
to change the timeline to make the
changes that they want - even though
he's only the bookends of the episode
there's a lot to unpack with the way
that he's going about manipulating
Sherlock like he goes into this big
tirade about how because he's a Welles
or he's inhabiting oh well he
understands the other versions of Welles
across the multiverse even though
reverse-flash is a genius in his future
so he's way smarter than everyone else
that also implies that it works both
ways so Sherlock will understand
reverse-flash in a way that the other
people on Team flash do not so that'll
just come back around the pipe pay that
off later this season over now Sherlock
is kind of busy I'll talk about his wife
in a second because there's a whole lot
of Easter eggs with the person that they
cast for that as well as what's going on
with her storyline number 9 though iris
is planned to spice up her newspaper
just goes completely off the rails so
the whole reason for what she's doing in
this episode is because everybody thinks
that her newspaper is totally lame
remember it's the central city's citizen
the one that becomes the future
newspaper that we've been looking at
since the pilot episode way back in
season 1
they even used the gossip blogger from
earlier this season to rag on her little
she's just like god damn it my people
hate my newspaper I guess I got to make
edgier stories so she just tries to go
after cicada in a much bigger way he
goes completely off the rails they
mostly wind up using her storyline later
in the episode - just so all the plots
together because the whole reason for
the big mission during the episode is
that they need a device to help make the
metahuman cure but number eight gold
base is running quote-unquote the market
from Geoff Johns thinker arc that the
blacksmith had been running Amunet black
so big callback to season four and a big
callback to the thinker arc from the
geoff johns era of the flash if you not
have become book reader when geoff johns
was still writing the flash comic during
the wally west era before
flash rebirth he did a thinker arc it
was very different from what the TV show
did with the character but while that
was going on wally west flash was also
dealing with the Rogues in Central City
so he had like a big conflict with the
thinker in Keystone City and you had all
the Rogues trying to come after him in
Central City the leader of that current
version of the Rogues was the blacksmith
Amunet black she had a black market ring
that she was operating in Central City
they called it the market so that's what
this market was from the episode gold
face is a really old flash villain but
he actually started out as a Green
Lantern villain during the I think was
the Golden Age of the Silver Age then he
went to Keystone City and became a flash
villain so for the most part he was
known as a flash villain but during that
Geoff Johns thinker arc where they were
doing the market gold face was just like
a normal criminal but a lot of his
actual powers are sort of a reference
way back to the Green Lantern era when
he first started out in the comics so
they literally made him a gold face
Barry the chemist knew about the melting
point of gold so he used that against
him later in the episode but there's a
bunch of other Easter eggs during that
big heist sequence so number seven
Barry's fake evil persona like the whole
thing about this episode is it was Barry
having to pretend to be bad the flash is
supposed to be one of the most
good-hearted heroes in the DC TV
universe Oliver is one of the few people
who has darkness within him so something
like this would be very easy for him to
pretend to be an evil person to get what
he needed so elongated man was not wrong
to be worried about how Barry was gonna
be able to pull this off but things went
off the rails anyway so it didn't really
matter that much but when Barry calls
himself
the chemist is just a reference to the
scientist the original episode where he
debuted during arrow season 2 episode 8
the title of the episode was the
scientist because Barry Allen is a
scientist but then you have all the
council of wells wives stuff a lot of
you may recognize the person they cast
to be his wife from the father of the
bride movies a long time ago she also
stars in a bunch of Lifetime movies she
did a movie with Tom Cavanagh a little
while ago obviously they had a
relationship so if you're fans of those
actors in real life I'm sure there'll be
a couple of Easter eggs for the projects
that they've done together but within
the world of the flash the way they
explain it is is that Sherlock is just
obsessed with this one woman and he just
marries her on every single world that
he goes to so they have fun with some of
the similarities between those different
versions of his ex-wife so he winds up
knowing just a little too much about her
and it's really creepy when they first
mean they just play it for comedy but
the Council of Welles wives obvious
twist on the Council of Welles we'll see
how this goes down I think they have a
little bit of fun with it the actual
Council of wells that they did last
season didn't quite live up to my
expectations I had been hoping for a
little more Rick and Morty spin on it
and they really just kind of played it
for slapstick comedy and it got like a
little too ridiculous for me so we'll
see how they tuned that for his wives
but we do learn that they've hired
breacher to get alimony from him when he
jumps to other Earth's that's why they
mentioned breacher in in the first
couple of episodes when he debuted he
said that he owed a lot of money to all
the different versions of his wife
I guess hanging out on the dragon farm
on the other earth wasn't enough for him
so that's what Danny Trejo has been
doing this whole time maybe he'll come
back on the flash sometime there was
sort of a subplot with Nora trying to
help him as part of this and she did
seem pretty genuine they just want to
make you seem like even though she's
doing something that's really
underhanded she's not an evil person
like she genuinely wants to help him
find love but it's all part of this
deception plot with the reverse-flash so
it's all being done for this really
shady reason so there are a lot of
moments in episodes like this where they
write her doing bad things but with a
really good heart so that you don't
completely throw her under the bus by
the end of the season number five bury
an elongated man do the Mission
Impossible fall out heist sequence a
couple of really good people having to
pretend like they're evil and steal from
a hospital and they laid it on thick
like elongated man is looking through
all the children that are gonna get
those special
organs like I can't steal from these
little kids this is terrible of course
it goes off the rails but number four
though big easter egg the hospital that
they're stealing from is part of Ivo
labs from the Elseworlds crossover
remember the ones that made the Amazo
android so it seems like some stuff from
the Elseworlds crossover that got mixed
up some of the reality changing stuck
after they fix things because originally
on arrow the Amazo was the boat the dr.
Ivo who was more of a scientist worked
on like there was no Ivo labs or
anything like that so the writers and
the producers just sort of winked at
that a little bit like oh maybe
something changed because of the
Elseworlds crossover maybe reality has
been warped and that's why we have the
real Ivo labs in the actual Amazo from
the comics now it was a really weird Rob
Zombie track on the laser tag sequence
that they had when they were trying to
take down the other criminals it felt a
little out of place totally with what
the flash has been doing lately and it
actually did look like laser tag when
they were taking down those criminals
because of the way those guns worked but
three the gold face literal gold face
fight I was actually pretty happy with
their special effects and when Barry
took him down using science science
all you have to do is electrocute
him a little the gold will heat up and
just melt right out of his face so it
was pretty good special effects I don't
know how he would add that mass back to
himself like what do you have to reheat
himself back up to soak that back up
into his eye so that his face would look
normal again
who knows - is the iris versus akkada
fight it was a little ridiculous but I
think this is all in service of that
twist at the end where she's like I have
an idea for how we can give him the cure
because she stabbed him with the pen in
his dark matter wound which I guess
based on the way their fight went down
he's weaker there because normally like
if you attacked him like the flash has
been attacking him all season long and
it hasn't fazed him at all so the fact
that iris was able to hurt him
significantly like you see him scream in
pain is probably just because of where
she actually stabbed him like if she
would have stabbed him anywhere else he
probably would have just shrugged it off
and thrown her across the room the way I
explained cicadas actions and the fact
that it took him so long to figure out
what was going on is because I don't
think that he's ever heard IRA speak or
seen her on TV so he doesn't know
anything about her being the wife of the
flash the whole idea that iris comes up
with at the end of the episode though if
it wasn't clear like the pen that she
picks up that she stabs him with that
gives her the idea that they'll just
shoot
him with the projectile that then we'll
release the cure into his bloodstream
never window was Sherlock's new wife
winding up again metahuman completely
shifting his focus Sonoran reverse
flashes plan worked better than she
could have ever hoped but this and that
twist with the Council of wells wives
implies that she's going to be a much
bigger character for the rest of the
season so you kind of see where his
ending is like if he is successful he'll
save her they'll wind up in a
relationship together and he'll go off
with her at the end of the season if
this version of Sherlock does not come
back and we get a different version next
season quick reminder to all of the DC
TV shows have been renewed early for
next season
so anything that his comic book on a CW
is coming back for another season
including arrow Black Lightning pretty
much everything you could imagine so the
mini flash arrow crossover though on the
arrow episode was because of the special
documentary that they were doing
narrated by Kelsey Grammer so they had a
special scene with Grant Gustin talking
to camera from a previous season about
Oliver Queen as the green arrow flute
like I'm a director
that's awesome I didn't just didn't
messed it up sorry Oliver is an
interesting guy
unbelievably damaged
[Music]
oh they won't let me say Amen
I don't mean well all I meant by that
was just that he's he's lived through a
lot of darkness and all he really cares
about is trying to make sure nobody else
has to go through what he's gone through
no no I didn't know you he was the green
arrow until he turned himself in I mean
it you know oh whoa
obviously big surprise of it you know a
guy
they had cameos from a bunch of other
actors like they had Quentin Lance in
flashbacks because he's dead in
present-day they had a scene with Thea
they had a scene with Sara Lance so they
had a whole bunch of DC TV people
talking about Oliver but some of the
interviews were taken from earlier in
the timeline but let me know in the
comments what was your favorite moment
from the flash episode and let me know
if there's any Easter eggs that you
spotted in the episode that I didn't
mention in the video what'll happen is
is there was a funny parody Wolverine
Deadpool ad and we got a whole bunch of
news about a brand new version of
Wolverine that Marvel is gonna cast when
Kevin Feige gets the characters they
also just released an official preview
of Game of Thrones season 8 so I'll be
doing those videos next they should be
up in a little while while you wait for
that click here to rewatch the Avengers
end game Super Bowl trailer with all my
easter eggs
and click here for the Captain Marvel
Super Bowl trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]